hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
question I'm going to answer a question
from a mere who's a face book reader who
asked about how can he make his team
stayed loyal and motivated and this is a
huge problem that a lot of entrepreneurs
face once you start to build beyond
themselves if it's just you then you got
to keep yourself motivated but when you
build beyond yourself and you have to
build beyond yourself if you want to
build a you know growing successful
company then you know what huge
challenge is keeping your team motivated
and loyal it's so hard to train new
people and find new people that if you
get the right person now with come into
your company you want to keep them for
as long as you can hopefully forever so
it's a couple of ways to do it the first
thing is you want to make sure your your
time their passion into their job role
at your company so hopefully they're
excited about the vision of your
business they like the industry that
you're in you want to tie what they're
really interested in learning and put
that into their job description so you
want you know your sales guy i really
love sales and that's what he breathes
lives and brings and loves doing you
want your programmer to love programming
right so you want to match up their
interest with their skills and sounds
may be obvious but in a lot of them
entrepreneur businesses a lot of small
businesses people are forced to do a lot
of things and you're often stretch to do
things that you're not excited about and
the people are doing things that they're
not passionate or excited about for too
long then they start to lose interest
they don't you know they're not as
productive they're not as motivated and
they're not as loyal to you so you want
to try to tap into what they're really
excited about my business what I try to
do is I meet with everybody on my team
quarterly a nasen what did like about
their job what they don't like about
their job we try to look for ways to
automate or outsource of things that
don't really like doing and things that
they're excited about or want to try and
learn about we give them a little bit of
rope people to do that to encourage them
to come up with ideas for our business
that you know they want to work on
beyond
their normal job description and that
helps win no loyalty and since the
project is their idea they're really
motivated to want to do it and keep
going we found that that that you know
really helps us turn to be able to go
out there and attract a talented
workforce texting is be nice I know a
lot of people have bad bosses and that's
why they they quit their jobs or trying
to move on to another opportunity so be
nice you know children respect show them
that you know they're appreciated in the
business it's surprising how few people
actually do that and take the time to
show them you know that you really
appreciate the work that they're doing
and you're given them a workplace that
they feel accepted in and love coming to
every day a lot of times out your ears
are so tied up and busy and what they're
doing and so stressed out about growing
their business that like that feeds on
to your employees and your team as well
so you gotta you'll make sure that
they're happy doing what they're doing
it's a good culture and a good office
that people want to come and work for
every day if you really love what you're
doing and you love your team and you
know your your love the culture at a
company it's really hard to want to
leave and it's really hard to be
unproductive and unmotivated so you want
to try to create that culture as much as
you can and the last thing I found that
really helps is you want to try to tie
in the day-to-day work of your team into
the bigger picture in some positions
like sales it's easy enough because they
see that now they're making money for
the business and they see the sales
numbers coming in and they get that
gratification where a lot of your other
team they may find it harder so if you
have people on your mentee more
programmers or you know other other
roles within the business it can be
really hard for them because they they
only see and breathe and live the
day-to-day grind that they're going
through you know as a part of their job
and they may have your minor wins with
the company but they don't see the big
things that happen at the business so
you want to make sure you tie in the
little actions that they're taking to
the big picture of where you're going
with the company and the direct impact
that they've had to help you move closer
to that vision the more I can show that
the work they're doing is helping people
the more they're going to like
doing their job the further that
disconnect is the more it feels like
they're just punching numbers and
they're not really having an impact and
not really helping people then it's
going to be harder to keep them
motivated one of the things we do is in
my role the business I get a lot of the
good feedback I get a lot of people
saying Thank You Evan that was a great
video or I love your newsletter or your
contents awesome I get to see all the
awesome stuff where are my team get to
see a lot of the crappy stuff
unfortunately so when we have 6,000
people who write for our website when
any of them have a problem or question
they write into one of my you know
support team and most of the time it's
only writing with questions or problems
it's never hey you guys are great so
they'll if you see the business who
they're ours it's often really bad like
all these questions problems so what I
kind of do is every month I send an
update on what we're doing with the
business where we're growing you know
problems were facing and winds that
we've had and I lost I'll always share
all the folks that have come in so some
of the great things you guys leave on
YouTube comments underneath I'll share
with my team to say hey you know you
guys who helped make this possible it's
not just me doing this all of your help
put all this together and that keeps
them motivated and no knows that the
company is doing the right thing and
we're helping people and kind of feels
that they're connected to the team as a
whole and keeps them motivated keep some
oil instead of you know just doing the
day-to-day grind up their business I
hope that helps lovely or you guys have
to think any strategies that you're
using to keep your team morale and
motivated or if you have a question you
can leave it in the comments below and
if you like the video and you want to
see more please give it a thumbs up
below it always motivates me when I see
those thumbs ups coming in so thank you
and we'll see you on the next episode
you
you